no prices are rising where do you think
they're going and why I think that over
the next year and a half gradually all
prices are going to go higher by the end
of next year might be closer say brand
to seventy dollar a barrel for two
reasons one the man is going to recover
much more importantly loyal price
implied that high marginal cost
producers from shale toward side of all
pagano produce less and more importantly
everybody around the world is now
reducing capital spending in all in
sector by thirty percent and over the
next few years that reduction in capex
spending is going to reduce the increase
in supply in the future and therefore is
going to affect prices in the future but
we're not going to go back to a world of
all prices a hundred dollar per barrel I
think the new normal in all mark is
going to be around 70 for the next few
years and why because of this because of
the production that's being effectively
the production capacity that's being
taken out of the market or the behavior
of the Saudis well the bigger service is
important because this how it is first
of all the one didn't want to lose their
market share so the side is better to
have lower oil prices for a while to get
rid of all the high marginal cost
producers maintain their capital
spending to force everybody else do
under investment into new capacity so
prices are low but the market share of
Saudi Arabia and the other Gulf is going
to be larger over time there are also
some geopolitical consideration with low
oil prices some of the geostrategic
enemies of Saudi Arabia weather is Iran
and Iran's supporting Syria whether his
rash are going to be weaker the main
motivation of the Saudis economic there
is also a geopolitical one